I'm curious about having the no credit
what your thoughts are on that because I
know you talk about buying your house in
cash and and and kind of your process
with that well buying a house with cash
means you don't need credit number one
number two if you don't have credit and
you want to buy a home with a mortgage
you do that with what's called manual
underwriting not all mortgage companies
know how to do that anymore Church Hill
mortgage that we've endorsed for almost
30 years do does know how to do that and
they can help you do that if you're
steady on your rent and you've been on
your job two years you have a good solid
down payment you do not need a credit
score to buy a house you get the same
premium excellent interest rate as if
you had a very high credit scor when you
do a manually underwritten situation